[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
[Music]
yeah I want a lot of recently million
dollars that's it 1.5 million how do we
tell me about I played the state of
Rhode Island one that sounds a little
bit ah what are you gonna do the money
scared whinny money my dream so you
better ruin it
Oh what would you do if I want a million
dollars for a car like bar I probably do
something gay the weekend
what'd you do this weekend vada
what happened David I was I was doing
comedy shows all colleges so going
around town how was that get a little
older he started not giving a [ __ ] about
did you see whatever you're not
interested about well so yeah I'm not
interested because nobody people refuse
to do college shows like even Bill Maher
said I'm not doing college shows but
doesn't that make you want to do it yes
that's why they're coming up cuz they
let the vacuum for us and and when you
do when you're doing these are you going
in with the mindset of how much can i
push it and get away with it or in a cap
tactful manner or are you doing it where
I don't give a [ __ ] I'm gonna say
whatever the [ __ ] I want and I'm gonna
see how many panties I can get in a
bunch so it really depends Saudis in the
bunch boxers in a bunch okay cool boxer
briefs boxers in the chod you know yeah
but we the first school was a Jesuit
school so I decide a contract that I
wouldn't curse once a Jesuit Christian
Catholic school yes it's like oh so it
was super straightforward I think I
learned about them on da Vinci Code yeah
so I decided not to
I will not decide it I didn't give me
money if I didn't I didn't cuss at all
yeah and so that clean comedy how did
you not cuss tell me David so joke
without custody I can't [ __ ] do it
Yeah right so like we were part of your
vernacular I mean we said i sat there
and i was like okay i was a pastor
before i could do this you know alright
so i just so we what did that what I
decide to do with these shows I opened
up
a comedic Q&A so we have a moderator
they ask me questions that people want
to know and then I open it up to the
crowd and they could ask whatever and I
just and I just improv comedy bits on
the spot cool so it kind of keeps me
sharp it shows that I could still do it
which was dope a little scared about cuz
I haven't done it in a couple years
I love cure nice I like working with the
crowd yeah so crowd work was was really
great so I kind of appreciated that so I
decided that the crowd work in the Q&A
is a lot better than just doing 25
minutes stand-up yeah because then I
don't have to understand feel the crowd
is I can get babies tell me what when
they ask questions yeah that makes sense
yeah so it worked out a lot better and I
think like they enjoyed it a lot better
too if they run other questions other
questions that means literally I suck
what was your favorite part of it was
there like something that was like I was
a stupid ask question was a memorable
question that means when people say
stupid [ __ ] I just roast the [ __ ] out of
them yeah I mean every now and then to
like somebody asked me to like like me
who's your favorite youtuber and who are
the one that you hate them up to oh man
well we get those all the time too like
who do you like working with who's your
favorite youtuber all that stuff yeah
and of course I answered it honestly and
I always get what's your favorite color
what's your favorite color Joe you
missed you missed uh Steve roasting
people and he was the [ __ ] moderator
at a panel roast it was tight I didn't
know I didn't know I was I didn't know I
was gonna be a moderator like I was told
that I was gonna be on this panel is
about sketch comedy and then I was just
on the panel about sketch comedy I
thought you were gonna be on a panel
like as a panelist but in then and
that's how it's written it's written
that way and then they have anything
like you're the moderator now does it
what I find this out as we're walking
man I walk to work all because you made
it so much better imagine if you were
thank you i it wasn't prepared at all
because they didn't tell me so three
minutes before I found out and then I
then I go into it cuz I don't know I
don't know one of these kids man on
YouTube no offense to any of them I
really don't know them and so when I'm
on the panel I find out like that there
was a couple douchebag sir and so then I
started to I wasn't like planning on
like roasting guy list is like hero so
obviously like you know this new
generation of youtubers I do skits and
sketches they don't know the difference
between two they don't know the
difference between like comedic video or
whatever right and so
opening lion was like hey what up
everyone thanks to welcome to playlist
live today's whatever panel is about
comedy oh I won't you guys tell me what
what's your version what do you think
about sketch comedy and then obviously I
don't all the answers so you could see
everyone kind of get uneasily what I
would like [ __ ] I've been making comedy
videos what is a skin yeah there's a
skit because all right moving on to the
first question so he was just like
putting these little drops of like
habanero sauce that if you're paying
attention like [ __ ] it's just like Oh
young kids it goes right over their head
oh yeah yeah that's so [ __ ] like what
comedy I don't know it was fun there was
a couple moments where it was pretty yes
pretty interesting because there's one
kid who just thought he's the most
extreme kid on the planet Earth
okay he thought that he was like the
george carlin him now like like he
really thought that he was saying some
[ __ ] that's like he's like hey look I
know I'm gonna get arrested but I do
think that poop is funny annoyed with
you like rebuttal to you like try and
tries he tries well he's just a kid
right so it's like I mean you know it's
not like I'm [ __ ] great I actually
think he's up old guy that's trying to
do young comedy that's what I thought
well I think everyone's a kid I guess
yeah see I gotta learn your thing dude
because like when I go to some of these
shows like I don't know how to pump the
brake you know I mean so somebody will
say something annoying and then I just
[ __ ] flame them you know so I gotta
learn how to do that while you'll lose
the crowd right so it's like um like
that's what I mean I wanted to god I
wanted to say so many things so badly
but but you just lose everyone cuz the
majority of the people that were there
were there to see this kid exactly and
so then it's like congratulations this
everybody hates you now but you made
your friend group laugh like you can't
step on their Jesus I was I was I was
hoping to get you guys laughing and
their kids laughing like that but you
did a good job that's what you're
planting over at us so the panel was on
this side we were sitting on this side
and he would like ask this question and
hear their answers and he looked over to
us like why just couldn't [ __ ]
believe some of the answers like I was
just like oh cool because it was like
there's the two very sweet very sweet
little girls very sweet twin girls
whoo but but they were there sweet look
at the blogs and see exactly who were
talking about great we're gonna get lots
of views we're gonna get lots of views
mom no they're very nice but like with
the but there was really fun because
they be asked questions about how to do
sketch comedy and they would be just
like well you just have it which is fine
by the way like comedy is not nobody's
nobody owns comedy and I don't own it
you guys are on it we don't own it but
comedy is so broad anyone could do it no
problem but but hearing them talk about
it like experts whose ribs this morning
I think they I think you're giving them
non of credit maybe their routine you
will the crowd that they were talking to
and they've done so many panels that
they were like what's the point of
saying all this stuff absolutely not you
give them too much credit I don't
disagree it was just funny as hell it
was funny as hell because like the idea
that they were crossing their legs and
like you know I could they were talking
Diane Sawyer about it I always been
invite to VidCon and playlist live I
will go I will go never get him I will
go as long as he and I get to be a
moderator at every single pedal I would
love nothing more I think my favorite
part of that whole panel experience cuz
we saw two panels back two bags
oh when reading the second one Gio was
on it oh thank you my favorite part of
that was the huge oh yeah do we do it
now Joe was like it he was like this oh
I can't do any more and just was like
Jess this is how great justice with Joe
she was like can somebody give me a
fission spinner yeah I had one of my
person like she's pacifying a kid like
she's reaching for the diaper bag and
then she puts it in his hands
if she preached spins it puts it in his
hands and then Joe's like oh it's
helping
[Laughter]
oh my god [ __ ] for you down yeah but
come on only we literally saw this dude
at a [ __ ] funeral like this I can't I
can't hear I don't want I don't want to
be disrespecting your the same thing
over and over and over and another thing
Tom yeah like you know in a funeral like
a Catholic funeral is the same they have
to do the chance so it's like over and
old and then same with the panel same
questions same answer five people saying
the same answer
same question another how do you deal
with negative comments how do you deal
with them having motivation I don't feel
motivated I need a negative like how do
you deal with the [ __ ] hater it's
like oh my [ __ ] god it's the same
thing I'm like I don't know how to do it
I was going nuts were you allowed to
curse on the panel oh I did anyway but
but it was fun because the kids they all
ask questions as if they're in the press
pool at the White House like Gyan saying
like they take the microphone and
they're like hi my name is Dustin so if
you could have donuts as shoes or if you
could have pizza as hair which would you
choose and why
and and I'll take my answer off the air
like [ __ ] like that or you're like oh my
and then all the youtubers like go like
yeah there's tickets so seriously like
like you're like I can't film festival
and they're terry gilliam and they're
being asked about the tree of life yeah
and he's like they're like [ __ ]
Gandhi and Jesus together not only it's
so like that on the panel's okay I found
it very funny and interesting that
whenever we'd be walking through like
the creator side of playlist like it's
like all these little teenagers and as
soon as you walk past them it's like
they have like this like air about them
like um this [ __ ] and I'm like calm down
guys they come on they probably are
though they probably got 30 more
number one but the number one video is
probably been in moon shoes like in a
[ __ ] like in a pool full of jelly
yeah you don't mean like it's what did
you what did you make that's all right
but we're just fine by the way it's it's
all different [ __ ] but I'm just it's
just fine I know I mean we play we play
Jenga videos and eat sardines for
punishment so from here on now yeah
we're not better than now changing my
brand I have to do it I'm gonna just be
a [ __ ] d-bag don't know what it's
like to be a [ __ ] douchebag for like
a year
what's it like you know to mean there
has to be a certain level of delusion I
just find it really annoying like you
know trying to talk to a lot of these
kids and just trying to like relate to
them on a human level but then as soon
as you point out like oh yeah you know I
think I'd have seen your video or
whatever then all of a sudden their own
you wait they own you never say that
[ __ ] they all knew after that it's like
it's like they put their fingers in your
butt and they're walking you around
after that really puppet yeah I just
told the story last week but like I
found out that if you literally if
people want to know that you know who
they are in this [ __ ] city like
literally when I first came here there's
this guy that used to work for like some
kind of like life insurance company and
he was just like talking because I was
you know this is my first came to LA I
was completely uncalled yet no what the
[ __ ] was going on I was like super
Sacramento and like he comes up and he
just like talking about all of his life
adventures where he's been and at this
point I was so [ __ ] fed up with it I
remember Abe my mater he's sitting there
next to me because I'm literally just
making fun of this dude for 30 minutes
he's punching me too late to stop doing
in front of like all the guests and he's
like well you know I'm going to what's
that beer fest in Germany it was a
birthday yeah I'm going I'm go to
Oktoberfest I'm like haven't heard of it
he's like in Germany I was like what's
that he's getting angry
he's like Germany is another Content
angry and it's amazing to like how
something that small can make somebody
that angry but they want to feel like
they know more than you but if you won't
give it to them they get angry yeah
people who act intelligent do that yeah
it's kind of crazy no and then by the
way the party's right like going to a
party where they're playing thump thump
music right then by the way I saw like
an old guy wanted
but when when they're good one you I
know it trust me I know it but I own it
the fire is when you see a little
five-year-old kid walking around like in
dancing that's what it gets weird and
it's like [ __ ] midnight yeah
oh [ __ ] there's my girls and feels like
a wedding like yeah like eight children
breakdancing on a dance floor except
they're stars though yeah there was a
bunch of junior high kids there was like
junior high [ __ ] go-go dancer boy oh
yeah they had two guy go-go dancers yeah
I'm like interesting I've never seen and
there are no parents I don't know where
the parents are due maybe they're there
but I just don't know it's it was the
most bizarre party rich kids don't have
parents do exactly I mean it was cool it
was nice to see rich get rich parents
send their kids on planes and just
saying you see rich kids send their
parents to playdates yeah that's what
exactly it was just so crazy seeing that
different world like such a different
side of YouTube I'm like I don't know
what the hell is going on here did you
guys see I feel like did I like walk
through a different dimension and I go
into a different world and I'm like what
the hell's happening well this is what
I've been saying cuz people like Steve
you such a hater you're so jealous and
it's like no no no this is all just a
different like you're not seeing what
I'm seeing the world that I see now that
you have seen it's a [ __ ] weird one
man sorry I'm glad I went and I probably
would go over here I think it's pretty
cool right yeah this is just cool just
be aware of full space that you're in
because I think sometimes we just kind
of get like tunnel vision of what our
spaces but this is actually the whole
thing I feel like we should go to the
YouTube summit the creators are
happening right now but we probably do
but I don't check the email because I
assume that I didn't get invited to
playlist or VidCon I just did so a
couple years three years ago during the
election [ __ ] Nicky got invited to go
like hear Hillary Clinton talking she
got to take a picture with her and I was
like I was like oh I know why they
didn't invite me so like they're afraid
of what the [ __ ] all say like they're
afraid they're all like ask some real
ass question because I'm like I'm tough
dog guy I'll [ __ ] go in there and
I'll be like hey what's up with this
things like that's why I didn't get
invited and then because I only took my
brand deals email once a year cuz that's
like my joking myself I checked it like
four months later and I got invited but
you're not a badass nobody gives us yet
they couldn't wait for you to go and I
was all like sitting at home during the
event like I'm a Corsican alphaCAT asked
question he [ __ ] suck in their dick
of course I love you Aman I'm just
kidding but you don't I mean like it's
like it's like oh yeah what a badass I
am yeah no not at all hey they were so
happy to have me that's a [ __ ] you put a
picture of a Muscovy duck oh look at
that oh yeah you know what the [ __ ] that
was my story there's these ducks that
came up to our Airbnb and I was just
like what kind of duck because they have
like some red stuff like a rigid red
face yeah they're they're called Muscovy
they look like that like warts or herpes
or something yeah so when else it looked
like a turkey [ __ ] dangler on their
face yeah they're pretty [ __ ] ugly
looking so I wasn't sure at first
because the ones that you had were they
were black weren't they yeah and the
ones I've seen were white so I was sure
but I remembered the red like [ __ ]
wax on their [ __ ] face uh-huh Varga
held him pretty views feeding him like
right out of his hand very friendly
there's a let me get a magnet but you
know I was going through a period where
I was like doing all those like muck
vials and cooking and I wanted to learn
how to make Peking Duck so I was looking
up what type of duck you should use if
there's any kind of difference Muscovy
duck popped up and that's when that ugly
[ __ ] [ __ ] popped up and I remembered
it for the rest of my life they cook
those ducks or no no no so muscovy ducks
are in the sense of like they're known
because they have more of a beef type of
flavor oh yeah so they're known to like
taste more like beef wait what's duck
did you have I have not had good duck
bro you've never had good not good so
how does full a good guy I went to three
restaurants so far and every time I got
duck it tasted like [ __ ] you know it's
not supposed to taste like that what do
you think
no well you know we know when [ __ ]
tastes like [ __ ]
that's not good tastes like [ __ ] Oh
[ __ ] I don't know which tastes like
which tastes like chicken or the egg
are you getting the western style like
the steaks now will you eat with the
fork and a knife or again the Chinese
style it's some kind of duck that's
covered a [ __ ] sauce I know that gravy
usually that duck is not fresh that's
why it tastes yeah you didn't get
[ __ ] fresh Peking duck oh I didn't
get that one
it's like slimy I feel like you just
walk into a Chinese restaurant and they
looked at you're like giving the [ __ ]
duck Yeah right to give it to me you
know he's getting like the French style
duck with a gravy yes it's that one get
orange sauce that that [ __ ] always it's
old like it's not fresh you're not but
that's about that yeah it's different
you get that Peking duck [ __ ] dude bro
you gotta get the duck I said that the
Chinese guy just grabbed from the Park
pond
yeah just yesterday [ __ ] snapped its
neck and hung it on us look like some
kid just gave it bread and it went and
then it got into a bag right
we joke about that [ __ ] but it happens a
real I happen in real life really you
saw it why because they're coming from a
village where like animals and [ __ ] is
like that's you eat that [ __ ] right yeah
so then they see the pot the duck at the
pond and they're like oh shoot the
[ __ ] America's rich free food for
everybody and then they just take it
home and in the city you had to like
kind of educate you know like hey guys
family ducks for bread feeding for your
eyes [ __ ] those [ __ ] gusto kill all
those things those crews you don't like
we don't like gooses those things are
[ __ ] believable GL Goosen I don't
like goose they're [ __ ] disgusting
have you ever ate a goose I know
viola is illegal because they're the
size of this table and they attack you
all in danger
Therese okay I haven't seen the turkey
in the real life from a distance if you
like I see them in Sacramento roaming
but I never look close to him sure
they're huge we were in Bali and I saw
wild turkeys there's turkeys what'd you
do just walking around did you do
anything
no because we weren't we're we're
already at a buffet so I was already
like Cosmo oh if you weren't at buffet
beautiful how are you I would have good
skin and Nina totally I don't know I
don't like [ __ ] those things those
things are gross I hope you don't like
plugging them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]